and just into The Newsroom the National  Park Service tells us that more parts of  badwater Road are back open here's a  look at video showing the flooding from  a few weeks ago that shut it down  Incredible video let's talk the  specifics now bad water road is open  from California Highway 190 all the way  to badwater Basin that means you can go  check out those Salt Flats immigrant  Canyon and upper Wild Rose opened up all  the way yesterday however there are no  through roads open in the park and most  entrance roads are still closed if you  want details and all that I know there's  a lot to soak in uh go to our website  they'll have it up shortly at  8newsnow.com they gave you all the  details that we just mentioned there so  that'll be on 8newsnow.com